متلازمه الهتره هل سبق ان سمعتم بها هي
حاله غريبه ونادره يلقي فيها المريض نكات
سخيفه بلا توقف ويضحك ويتصرف بغرابه تم
تشخيص اول حاله من متلازمه الهذره عندما
احضرت هذه الزوجه زوجها للطبيب بعد ان فاض
بها الكيل فزوجها كان لا يتوقف عن سرد
نكاته السخيفه طوال الوقت لدرجه انه كان
يوقظها من نومها ليسمعها نكته المتلازمه
تجبر صاحبها ايضا على ارتكاب تصرفات غريبه
كالرقص امام الغرباء بلا خجل واثناء كل
ذلك ينغمس المريض في الضحك على تصرفاته
وتعليقاته هذه المتلازمه يمكن ان تحدث
بفعل عامل واحد او عده عوامل منها الاصابه
بمرض حاد او مزمن او تناول ادويه معينه
تؤدي لتغير كبير في القدرات العقليه وينتج
عنها تشوش التفكير ونقص الوعي بالبيئه
المحيطه